if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
ducks dumps dumps
[Music]
[Music]
that led him to lose the election which
is
where there's tremendous amounts of
water where the water rushes out to sea
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to once
dumps dumps dumps
[Music]
dump
[Music]
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost costing the election
what is going on here
what is going on
dumps
[Music]
that that dude is gone
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks oh joe rogan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you pac-man never talked to the new old
motor because pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
when i was telling my children who not
to be it's happening
smarter than you this is better than you
the
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
[Music]
trump was doing this with his personal
toilet
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks
[Music]
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
all right i love the image of clogged
shoes there that's just that's extra
special i really do like that welcome
everybody this is the last stream of
febrile february
um tomorrow being march i will have to
come up with some new adjective to
describe
um to describe trump's screeds i guess
uh we've got a um
you know this is i i wanna i don't wanna
interrupt here and call out a user named
wtf2020
but i have to tell you because i'm no
longer addressing idiocy on the show in
a serious manner i want to give you guys
an example of the stuff where people
think they're being clever but they just
don't even really understand what i do
this user wtf 2020 on tv where by the
way we have a hype train going on twitch
we have 15 seconds to make it to level
three i i don't know if we're gonna make
it we have eight seconds oh god
oh my god we didn't make it
okay well that's too bad anyway this
user wtf 2020 put just they think
they're clever they posted i'm old
enough to remember when david pakman
said keeve would be captured within
hours on friday
do people not understand
that i am reporting
what journalists and elected officials
say
okay
this is like the fox news audience who
watches and they go i don't know uh
tucker reported that critical race
theory is bad no
tucker gave an opinion
and
when we talked on friday the word was
intelligence officials believe
keiv could be taken within hours
i'm reporting to you guys and sourcing
things it's just so weird when people
come in here david you were wrong
because you no no no no guys those
aren't my opinions it's sort of like
when people call in and they go david
does iver muktin work for kovid
and i go well i don't have an opinion of
it myself
the evidence so far
in actual double-blind randomly
controlled trials doesn't show that ivor
mechtin works for covid and then later
people david
david you were wrong about ivermectin no
no no no
was i wrong that at the time
give me a so i have very little patience
for these people who just don't seem
they don't know what's going on it's
like they they live in a daze
um
how would i independently i'm not a
military analyst
this is not the type of show where i go
guys
my opinion is kiev will fall within
hours no way i'm not in a position to
have an opinion about that
what i can tell you is what are
government officials and others saying
what's great
is that
the kiev ukrainian resistance
has done better than expected in
repelling the russian invasion and we're
going to talk about that okay you guys
get it you guys i mean again it's like
um
all right let's go next to the big news
of the day
there is now a concern
that vladimir putin
might be willing
to use nuclear weapons now for everybody
who's going to show up in a week and go
david
on the last day of february
you said putin would nuke ukraine no
no
what what i'm reporting to you is
putin is now alluding to using nukes the
way he's alluding to it
is by saying we are going to put our
nuclear forces at a higher level of
readiness
and putin is claiming to justify that by
saying well
we've got to respond to the hostility of
the sanctions the sanctions of course
that he caused
by invading ukraine
um so
that is obviously a major concern
there's kind of two big sides on this
there's some people who say this is just
posturing from putin there is no way in
hell that putin would ever nuke use
nukes and by the way
who would he use them on he wants
ukraine but he's gonna nuke ukraine and
then take it over that's crazy he
wouldn't destroy the thing he's trying
to steal
there are other people who are saying oh
no no putin's unhinged right now whether
it's because he's lost his marbles
whether it's because he's terminally ill
you know whatever speculation
there's a contingent that says putin
will do anything at this point in time
there's nothing including nukes that
putin will not use and then there's
everything in between
now joe biden let me see if i can get i
am trying to do the best possible stream
for you that i can
um
earlier okay president joe biden was
asked whether americans should be
worried about nuclear war
and biden said no mr president should
americans be worried about nuclear war
no
okay so very simple just just to know
uh again these are not my opinions i
hope people understand what they're
watching here okay um so far
joe biden
has been pretty accurate in terms of
what to expect he at one point he said
this is what russia's doing and they're
starting to signal they might invade
then at another point he said our
intelligences putin has decided to
invade then putin invaded
okay so so far
that's what we've heard from biden and
he has mostly
mostly been correct
um all right i want to make sure because
it's such a special day in that it's the
last day of the month i want to make
sure everybody who deserves it is being
thanked but that no one who doesn't
deserve it is being thanked
i want to say thanks to grim reaper jay
tandaway small fuzzy moss
jen here
agent 71 kind af christina ftw
another one from jen here omi bedomi
xc and dexy wow xe and dexy you you
typically only see one of them
putting us at 11 already from the
standpoint of twitch prime and i would
love it for you guys to sign up on my
website with the coupon code please
don't war also available is the coupon
code obama
if you want it
oh also thanks to arundel
for the twitch prime subscription before
we have so many different things to look
at i don't even know where to start
there is a live united nations security
council discussion of the russian attack
on ukraine let's listen to the russian
dude
as regards the
draft proposed by france and mexico the
humanitarian situation in ukraine we
need to study the text very carefully
before issuing any assessment thereof
in any event
please know that the russian military
will provide any needed humanitarian
assistance to the ukrainians in the
territories
that have been freed from the radicals
i now resume my function as president of
the council
and give the floor to the representative
of ukraine
wow
[Music]
this is the guy who earlier said putin
should kill himself we'll get to that so
mr under secretary general
high commissioner
first of all i would like to thank the
security council for addressing this
urgent issue
every new day of the russian unprovoked
war against ukraine
increases the human sufferings across
the entire country
i would also like to express my sincere
gratitude to the secretary general for
his powerful statement
and relentless engagement with the
situation in my country
this is major stuff by the way guys okay
it's the appointment of mr amin award
as assistant secretary general to serve
as u.n crisis coordinator for ukraine
as i know he has arrived to geneva and
resumed his duties
this is live
his mission will be extremely difficult
against the backdrop of the ongoing
russian military activities
that are often
equaled to war crimes
at the same time millions of ukrainians
will require his attention in particular
our children women elderly and other
vulnerable citizens
so i wish him and his team strengths and
mercy
in their work
distinguished members let us be clear
this is not
only a security crisis
this is a humanitarian crisis yes
this war of choice is not only a
violation of international code
it violates the conscience of the world
security assistance is needed but
it alone is not enough we call on the
international organizations to provide
us with
humanitarian assistance we call on you
to register all cases
in which international law and
international humanitarian law are
violated
almost all speakers and breakers today
were unanimous in their assessments
the situation in ukraine could
deteriorate sharply
let me provide you with the latest
available information from the
government of ukraine
today is the fifth day of a full-scale
unprovoked and unjustified war launched
by russia against ukraine
launched by russia against the very
heart
of europe
launched by russia against the idea and
ideals of democracy
it is the most horrible and large-scale
invasion since world war ii it appears
to be
in the morning i told the general
assembly about the shellings of the
residential city of kharkiv
by russian grads
killing and wounding dozens of innocent
civilians
now the residents of kiev the home of
three million innocent people
and its suburbs are sitting within
russian crosshairs right now by the way
uh
some russian propagandist will get to
the clip later said that the claim that
there are people dying in ukraine is
fake news he's like no nobody's dying uh
2040 people this is live guys
children live live live
russia keeps
attacking kindergartens and orphanages
russia is attacking hospitals
if true that's a war crime gates
with shell fire and sabotage groups
russia fired in ambulance crews near
zappos and kiev
let me say that again
so that you can see this image in your
mind
russia is attacking hospitals
mobile aid brigades
and ambulances
this is not the action of a state with a
legitimate security concern
this is the action of a state determined
to kill civilians
there is no debate
these are war
crimes these attacks violate the rome
statute
and these attacks are far from
over
now just a quick note
russia signed the rome statutes but then
said actually we're out so
you know it's it's sort of like a minor
detail but russia could be like we're
not even really party to that we bailed
on that mental disaster and even
radioactive contamination
international humanitarian law is critic
is crystal clear
none of these facilities are legitimate
military targets that's true the
civilian population of ukraine is the
first to suffer from such attacks
and if we do not act today it will be
far from
from the last
we welcome this statement issued today
by the
icc prosecutor kareem han
on the situation in ukraine
the statement about his
decision to proceed
with opening an investigation
in his statement the icc prosecutor
says that he reviewed the office's
conclusions arising from the preliminary
examination of the situation in ukraine
and has confirmed that there is a
reasonable basis to proceed with opening
an investigation
in particular he is satisfied that there
is a reasonable basis to believe that
both electable crimes and crimes against
humanity have been committed in ukraine
seems clear they have to the events
already assessed during the preliminary
examination by the office
given the expansion of the conflict in
recent days it is his intention that
this investigation will also encompass
any new alleged crimes falling within
the jurisdiction of his office
that are committed by any party to the
conflict on any part of the territory of
ukraine
the prosecutor will also be asking for
the support of all state parties and the
international community it is nuts that
russia runs the u.n security council
right now i mean that is it that is
crazy traditional budgetary support for
voluntary contributions
to support all our
his
situations and for the loan of gratis
personnel
the importance and urgency of the
prosecutors it reminds me of when when
saudi arabia was and they may still be
on the un civil rights commission it's
like come come on guys please
to my colleagues from around the world
this affects you too
russian military aggression kills not
only ukrainians but threatens thousands
of foreigners who are staying in ukraine
the ukrainian government is doing his
best to facilitate their passage at the
state border
even as the border has become
overwhelmed with the massive influx of
people fleeing russia's armed aggression
temporary volunteer assistance points
have been set up at the border to
provide foreign students with food and
cata
for other humanitarian needs
please do not be misled by russian
disinformation there is no
discrimination based on race or
nationality and if there if there are
cases they should be investigated
journalists working in the free press
also are on the fire during live reports
from the scenes of action and hard spots
a journalist and a photographer working
for the danish newspaper extra blooded
were injured when their car was targeted
in akhdirka district hosumi region
ukrainian children are crossing the
eu-ukraine border without their parents
and without powers of attorney from
their parents
in this regard we request
decision makers in the eu countries to
provide clarifications and instructions
to eu institutions in order to secure
free movement
of and assistance to such underage
persons and their guardians
according to the ministry of education
of ukraine more than 350 000 school
children have no access to education
schools are closed due to severe
insecurity in civil areas across the
country
the numbers of refugees are being
assessed the numbers could be hundreds
of thousands of people who have been
forced to flee across international
borders into neighboring european
countries mostly poland slovakia and
romania
it can take several days of waiting to
cross the border and we are grateful
that more checkpoints on the border with
poland have been opened including two
additional pedestrian crossings for all
who want to get from ukraine
to the neighboring safe country
cave local authorities have set up a
coordinating humanitarian headquarters
to provide food and basic necessities to
those in need
an electronic platform will be launched
tomorrow on this platform on this
platform businesses will be able to
provide information about their
available resources and key if residents
will be able to announce their needs
all of this information will be system
systematized for effective communication
and distribution of essential goods
august definitional device prime
minister of ukraine who has been
appointed as a government coordinator
for humanitarian assistance working 24
7.
there are many urgent things to do
like to agree on humanitarian corridors
to evacuate civilians from the most
endangered territories however
i need to warn you not to be misled by
russian assurances of security
russian wars often if not always do not
match their deeds
for instance just recently we heard
russian politicians and diplomats
even here in this chamber who said that
there would be no invasion no attacks on
ukraine hence these corridors can be
easy targets to the russian army
to help people at the border crossing
points in western regions of ukraine who
are waiting for crossing for at least
one to two days
to provide assistance to idps in western
regions of ukraine
including housing schools jobs guys
these are the full subtitles you're
missing like one line of pixels there's
nothing below it these are the subtitles
from markets
including in the occupied
territories
distinguished members of the security
council this is this is not only a
security crisis
this is a humanitarian crisis as i said
before
the russian war against ukraine has
brought the entire region to the brink
of humanitarian catastrophe
let me therefore repeat our call to the
international organizations to provide
all possible humanitarian assistance and
to register all cases in which
international law and international
humanitarian law are violated
you have all heard the lies from the
russian site lies in moscow lies in the
general assembly and lies in security
council
distinguished members of the security
council and friends around the world
do not listen to russian lies
listen
to ukraine's
cries
listens to the cries of men
women
and children who have lived in peace
who deserve to remain in peace
who and who will forever support your
own nation's efforts to for peace across
europe and around the world
russia has tried and failed to defend
its lives
but the people of ukraine with the help
of the world
will never fail to defend
our land what's up do not listen to
russia's lies listen to ukrainian cries
we need your help
the russian ambassador laments
that a dozen of russian spies
won't be able anymore to enjoy all the
benefits of american life
while doing things uncompatible with
their status used as a cover-up yeah
the russian ambassador should instead
work hard
to report to his superiors that
only his cronies a bunch of cronies by
his narrative here in the united nations
i want to conclude
with saying that
i am looking forward
to midnight
even though the midnight is the most
dangerous time right now because
that's when the
most of the attacks take place
but i'm looking forward to midnight
when this abomination
occupation of the seat of the president
of the council
will be over
i thank you
wow
wow i see jesse
i would like to now
give the photo to martin griffiths and
felipe grandy and ask them to answer the
question that we put when we made the
statement about the placement of heavy
weaponry in residential areas
in
ukrainian towns and how is this in line
with international humanitarian law
thank you
so i guess what he's saying is
well
if civilians are getting killed which
they say they aren't it's because you
guys are putting artillery near
civilians which we are then shooting
no confirmation of
such reports uh
of um radicals placing such weaponry in
residential areas
the fact is that accountability at this
stage
for breaches of international
humanitarian law which we must see
in time
is naturally at this level
of the conflict and this level of the
violence at this level of the
uncertainty very difficult to establish
we are truly in a period of a fog of war
a fog which obscures the futures of so
many people this is starting to
it's been surreal it's getting doubly
surreal points uh i would add in in my
remarks in my briefing
about our fears of the impact on
civilian objects civilian infrastructure
as a result of urban warfare
i mentioned for example mr president
our uh
reminder
that
large-scale urban warfare
also requires the need
to avoid the wide area explosive weapons
we are very very concerned at what we're
seeing now in the streets
of some of the key
large
modern cities of ukraine
the way in which people are voting with
their feet
uh the way in which
basic services are being interrupted
yeah
and the way in which civilian
infrastructure is being damaged
and we will
in time
i am quite sure
discover
who did what
and who broke which requirements of
international humanitarian law thank you
very much that is a threat if people are
unsure that is your problem thank you
now
i wanted to ask philippa granty do you
want to take the floor
uh no thank you
mr president i fully support what
the undersecretary general just said
thank you
there are more no more names described
on the list of speakers but before
adjourning the meeting i would like to
say that whilst uh
listen to our briefers i was surprised
because just the reports and videos and
information in ukraine some of them are
taken as fact and others
which are obvious uh the ones that we
have in the in to internet this guy's
disgusting by the way questionably or
reliable
are
being considered all inaccurate
unreliable
are
considered not to be
verified well we're going
have
drawn lessons from that and
we're learning some lessons all right
the u.n leadership will tell us
how the ukrainian activities are to be
considered there are no more names
inscribed as i said but before
adjourning the meeting as this is the
last scheduled meeting of the council
for the month of february i would like
to express a sincere appreciation of the
delegation of the russian federation to
the members of the council and the
secretary of state for all the support
that they've given to us it was a busy
month we managed to
get to consensus on several important
issues within our preview although as
you know not on everyone i would like to
once again thank all the representative
of the secretariat including the
conference services in terms of he's
acting like they agreed on the lunch
menu for next month for the preschool
dear staff
our presidency is coming to an end and i
know i speak on behalf of the council in
wishing the delegation of the united
arab emirates good luck in the month of
march the meeting is adjourned
i would never advocate violence if
someone open-handed slapped that guy in
the top of the head
as he walks out it wouldn't shock me i
mean this it's it's just incredible
what's going on
um
oh my god what what an absolute disaster
so we're gonna get to all of these
things this is the adjournment of the un
security council um
and uh of course the big news is that
putin is alluding to using nuclear
weapons if you're just joining us please
keep it here as we're going to continue
monitoring everything that is going on
and we're monitoring multiple feeds all
over the place and and following
following everything quite frankly
um it's the last day of the month and i
have i have such an incredible agenda to
get to over the next uh period of time
with you guys and i'm so glad that
you're here welcome everybody watching
on youtube twitch and facebook please
don't go anywhere
uh about 10 000 people watching with us
right now and i really appreciate that
thanks to dan cutter as well as bradley
hughes for signing up on my website i
really appreciate that also everybody
watching on twitch including hajil
webtech jenny 6lj
demiduce
xanamakes
and bonemaster all of you really
appreciate that putting us at 21 for the
day just because it's the last day of
the month and it's not been a good month
and february as many of you as you know
only has 28 days most years
uh we are doing something we've never
done before through midnight eastern
tonight
i am blowing out memberships we have a
coupon code it's only valid for the next
seven hours
it's no putin no february no putin no
february all one word you've got to know
how to spell putin you've got to know
how to spell february february remember
that it's 75 off at joinedpakman.com
we've never done anything like it before
let's do it it's not been a
the best month because it's only 28 days
guys it's only 28 days so for
february
no putin no february is the code and the
first person to use it on my website
i'll also send you a free item from my
online store okay
let's go i mean i don't even i have so
much stuff first
since the russian invasion of ukraine
started the amount of insane voicemails
and hate mails that i'm getting are
completely off the charts here's just
one such example
yo what up david pacman i pull up with a
track man i'm a love you boy and i said
yeah man you boy it's been a while since
i heard that hey
what's up david i just wanted to ask you
why you always talking about the side of
your [ __ ] mouth my boy
you always like moving your lips like
it's true i move my lips when i talk
that i
guilty as charged sir
like like zip lip and then you go
you know move it to the right i start
talking it's [ __ ] you look like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude um
hey
i talk
out
of
the side i mean what is this
that's all i gotta say you [ __ ]
stupid ass [ __ ]
right the [ __ ] david
pack woman
oh
oh boy
little uh misogyny there huh so anyway
that came in here's another one
you're just another worthless damn
democrat
go [ __ ] yourself
uh i am not a democrat i have never been
a democrat
are you today or have you ever been a
member
of the democratic party no
no i have not
so that's going on there's a bunch of
people who want to be unbanned from
twitch they were banned for completely
toxic behavior uh i do have a gavel here
with which i can adjudicate them being
unbanned
here's a user named beasty wolf
who came in here and said
what what did they even say
uh
actually
i'm just gonna unban it's not even clear
why they were banned they're unbanned
let me go to somebody else here's
another user
charmhole
who came in and said
david do you answer questions on twitch
or is this channel for money laundering
only okay yeah accusing us of
criminality is a
and then um someone came in and said
trump2024 i'm gonna unban i don't
actually we're not banning for trump
2024 that's a political opinion trump
2020 i can i know this is subtle and
nuanced trump 2020 i consider to be
trolling because it's over trump 2024 as
long as you're not multi-spamming it in
all caps like 20 times i would allow
trump 2024 it's just an opinion of who
you're supporting in 2024
so that we allow okay
a giovanni says via super chat does that
mean president putin could be charged
with war crimes our prayers are with
ukraine i mean yeah he could be but you
know i mean
you know you're not gonna get you're not
gonna get putin on that
thanks to ham hair
for the twitch prime subscription you're
number 22 the first person today to use
the very powerful new coupon code
um
what is the code no putin no february
the first person to do that is adam
bennett adam you have won a free item
from my online store email info
davidpakman.com to collect also thank
you to some other great people signing
up on my website glennrattner kathy
hinson jesse david
debbie heyer
brian simmons and colby cole whoa
scotty h
and david roberson
laura ray christian friar this is like a
huge dump of memberships
yonas tamiyav
anthony baez
michelle tucker
dexyco
and buvana pathy oh sorry and one more
tony roughcar 16 new members putting us
at 39. it's the last day of the month
never before seen 75 off coupon code is
no putin no february let's continue
because i have so much more for you guys
this is something very interesting i
don't remember doing this clip this is a
clip from november of 2017.
apparently someone called me and said
david what happens to trumpists after
trump i have no memory of what i said
but a viewer told me david you've got to
look at this on a stream because what
you predicted was exactly correct let's
listen to what i said
five years ago four and a half years ago
and see if i was right all right let's
see who else is on the phones because
there are a lot of people here waiting
uh let's go to our caller from the 818
area code caller from 818 what's on your
mind
hey david so i think it's fair to say
that no matter what happens with the bob
ball investigation trump's approval
probably won't dip below like 25 or 30
percent like no matter what happens uh
maybe a quarter of the country will just
stick with them to the bitter end i
think so what i'd like to ask yeah what
i'd like to ask is
even when trump is gone what happens to
these people because like i find it
funny to look at trump's supporters
online but i also find it kind of
disturbing to see
kind of like how easily
exploited they are and how willing they
are to be exploited by somebody as
stupid as trump
so
um
yeah like have we basically entered an
idiocracy age in american politics like
is there going to be a trump 2.0 will uh
well listen there's a couple different
ways this could go it's an interesting
question what happens to the trumpist
after trump what what is a post-trump
world like for trump is do they just see
it i have literally no idea what i
answered on this question as as the
golden era as so many ideological
conservatives now see the 1950s that
that's what we would like to get back to
i don't know i think that there will be
significant i actually worry that post
trump you might see significantly
increased levels of violence from
trumpists that's that's one question
even if he has a successful presidency
to their standards
yeah i think that after he's gone if
things don't go the way that they
uh expect them or believe that they
should go that they might they might
become significantly inflamed wow
i think the the broader question is
does trump trigger for lack of a better
term
trump 2.0 trump 3.0 does trump
legitimize the idea of sort of a
clueless buffoon
being a president and that is that
that's the biggest concern for me
because i think the answer is yes i
think the answer is yes because even
with only 25
you can basically with with 50 voter
turnout you can win an election
with i mean at certainly with 26
approval even less if you get the votes
in the right states because of the
electoral vote system so that's really
the concern for me the idea that now
we're going to get trump 2.0 and 3.0 and
that it'll be a an absolute mess wow
well i mean interesting yeah i mean some
of that stuff certainly has happened so
that's it's interesting to look back
into
and to see that and certainly i mean
we've we have now trump 2.0 and 3.0 in
congress right i mean madison cawthorne
uh
marge greene and uh lauren bober bobert
all of it it's it's a sad circumstance
there's no doubt about it it's a sad
circumstance but
desantis right exactly exactly
is there any mention of sanctioning
belarus for their involvement i it's
i've heard it whispered but i don't know
what's going to happen with it
david you're a funny may fake a keep
doing you okay thank you that's fitznuts
that's it sir that clip proves you're
part of the deep state working with the
illuminati how else could you predict
the future that is a freaking predator
right there hatman's a loser yeah
um thank you to snappy tam and r rhino
as well as matt frazier for the twitch
prime subscriptions guys this is the
last day of the month if we get to a
hundred members i'll open phone lines
just to celebrate the end of the month
oh and we may get there i want to say
thanks to anna philhauer look at all
these people signing up on my website
elizabeth davis thank you corey schutz
is a new member shayna hager
jack mclain
eliana del rio joe camarieri
sid beauchemin i feel like i'm doing
okay with name pronunciations today
thanks to jeff kelly and welcome to
justin jones on my website also corey
powell
and philip crader all signing up on my
website that's 10 more folks putting us
at 52. we've got a last day of the month
membership special we've never ever ever
seen it before but we are looking at it
strongly and the code is no putin no
february 75 off ends at midnight and
people are very very distraught by it
okay here is a cnn report of a destroyed
column of russian military vehicles
outside kiev
given the limited resources of what's of
of of the ukrainian resistance and
military it's incredible what is going
on go
right within the past few hours look at
it has been a ferocious battle here on
the outskirts of kiev and this is one of
those russian soviet era vehicles which
is completely burned out you can see
this is a bridge actually is an access
point to the north west of kiev the
ukrainian capital
and the russian column that has come
down here has been
absolutely hammered obviously we're
still in a very exposed
situation right now but this is crazy
there's the debris everywhere the
twisted metal of these vehicles this is
obviously just a
just a truck carrying supplies
we saw the armored vehicle in front
there
i mean looking around
absolutely look at this i mean what kind
of munitions does it take
to do that to a car to a vehicle you
know i know that i've speaking to the
local ukrainian commanders here they've
been saying that they were using western
anti-tank missiles okay and we're gonna
so so you get the idea i believe that
there is uh gore at the end of the video
so we're gonna get away from that uh
before we get another like 10 bans on
every platform here is jen saki the
white house press secretary uh
again asked
might joe biden send the u.s military
and she says no for many people who are
living there right now just lastly um
you know you've been very clear that the
president does not have any intention to
deploy
u.s troops
should engage militarily in this
conflict but would you say that there is
any particular red line that this
administration has that would
necessitate military action
as in sending our u.s military into
ukraine
the president has no plans to send us
military to fight a war in ukraine
against russia right they're being
extraordinarily clear about that and of
course the difficulty is
how can you do more and more which
clearly both the american people and the
international community want western
powers to do
without doing that and it appears as
though
that is a very hard line for joe biden
and i agree with that line certainly uh
here is that same um russian ambassador
to the un vasily nebenzia
who is now doing the fake news stuff
very very trumpian saying that the
reports of hundreds of ukrainian
civilian casualties are quite simply
fake news reports
about 100 civilians that there are a lot
of reports today and i said that there
are a lot of fake news there are a lot
of fake factories that produce there is
a fake news guys he says those news by
the way most of the fake news factories
are in russia it's funny there's there's
this weird thing that that's very
similar between russian and trumpian
propaganda
it's riddled with projection
and it's funny to talk about fake news
factories the most prominent fake news
factories are in russia
uh very very good long-form pieces about
the internet research agency one such
organ and i use the term organization
loosely
we do not have we do not have credible
reports on on civilian casualties
of course warrior is a bad thing and
nothing anything can happen war is bad i
mean they started one yes and war is bad
they started an optional one there there
wouldn't be a war right now were it not
for them
but uh to call this to to consider those
reports credible uh
is uh is very difficult since we are we
are witnessing and we are encountering
massive propaganda campaign reports
uh there's definitely a propaganda
campaign that's uh that's that's that's
for sure that's for sure
um
a commanding pr presence in videos of
bravery have made zolensky an
international hero how will this play
into putin's psyche it's got to be
destroying him it really does
because
zelensky was not
particularly popular before all of this
he really wasn't
and
this has had the effect of
first it seems from the intelligence
community that um
russia expected
to quickly be able to overwhelm ukraine
that didn't happen they're taking
they're taking casualties for sure and
taking equipment losses and other things
in addition to that zielinski has become
so popular and this i'm not praising him
i'm not ignoring any of the things that
he's done wrong in the past i'm just
standing in fact
the world is now for the most part
coming to the defense of ukraine and
it's got to be absolutely crushing putin
based on what we know about him
you should cover the destruction of the
an225
yeah i don't know much about that
destruction an225
um
[Music]
it was destroyed in russian strikes
yeah the
an225 is this monstrous plane
uh and it was destroyed in a russian
attack on an airfield was it
accidentally destroyed by russia where
the plane was let's see
was destroyed in an attack
in ukraine
yeah i i'm gonna have to research what
happened but it has been confirmed
destroyed that is true
it was at kiev airport at the time okay
fair
fair
um let's continue here
here is footage of um russian forces in
ukraine marching back to russian
territory and civilians are thanking
them for leaving
interesting
[Music]
so there's that
uh here is the ukrainian ambassador to
the united nations basically saying
putin should just kill himself he
shouldn't kill other people and if he
just wants to precipitate his own demise
like for example by considering nukes
he should just do what hitler did we
have been prompted to call for an
emergency special session
as the level of the threat to the global
security has been equated to the to that
of the second world war
or even higher following putin's order
to put an alert russian nuclear forces
what what a madness
if he wants to kill himself
he doesn't need to use nuclear arsenal
he has to do what he's saying what what
the guy in in berlin did in a bunker
in may
1945
right
right
um
wow
wow a lot happening guys a lot happening
some people reacted to that by saying
based in blue-pilled i don't even really
know what that means but i would never
suggest anyone take their own life um
this is one of those things where
what i think is being said is if putin
has a death wish if putin is as some are
speculating terminally ill or has lost
his mind or whatever right like if putin
is determined to kind of go go out
be taken out
he could do it in a way where he doesn't
harm other people i think is the point
that people are saying
and um
man
this this it's a surreal situation
absolutely surreal situation
okay so we did this
oh here's a report by the way about the
an-225 let's see a shocking end to an
aircraft that has seen more than 30
years of service dating back to the days
of the soviet union the an225 was
sometimes drafted
to help airlift aid during crises in
other countries
it proved to be useful during the
pandemic for bringing medical supplies
from china to kiev it later flew to many
more countries with medical aid and
supplies experts say that the plane's
restoration is possible but it would
cost over 3 billion us dollars and a
long period of time 3 billion on the
broadcast this minute is the myth
i thought planes were in the hundreds of
millions range three billion dollars
uh let's see boeing 747.8
cost new this is the new right even the
748 is 418 mil how would it be 3 billion
i know it's a big plane
that that's that is wild it's uh it's
bearable it's controllable and uh
i mean we are defending our land we are
defending our soil we are defending our
our people our children our country and
our future
so for us uh
it's something that we do
with uh
with some duress but i i if i can say
the word pleasure because i think
there's uh this is a noblest thing one
can do in his life is to defend his own
country um we didn't call for it we
didn't start it wow
we wanted to go on in peace and as a
member of ukrainian parliament our our
own future in uh in the european family
but that is what russia decided that is
what uh putin decided they decided to
unleash this war to unleash this
aggression and to invade our country so
uh
what church the stock of a weapon right
there to defend it
dimitro how optimistic are you about the
ukraine russia talks at this point what
are your expectations
but i mean uh
what are we talking about
while they're holding the so-called
negotiations
uh haruki the second largest city in
ukraine has been heavily shelled
and not just on some infrastructure or
military
objects but um residential areas have
been shelled uh
civilian uh civilian population has been
sell
sold
members of parliament are taking up guns
in ukraine guys
uh wow
can you imagine josh hawley doing this
give me a break
so
what do you want to negotiate after this
i mean what is the negotiation is
supposed to be
uh
are they expecting us to do any
trade-offs after shelling out people who
didn't deserve it who are not even
military people like just random
civilian people with children old ladies
and stuff like that uh i doubt they're
gonna be any negotiations in terms of
the result and in terms of the
efficiency all right so he's not super
optimistic here about
the negotiations that are that are
taking place uh oh boy it is getting
very very ugly this is a weird super
chat remember when we spent hundreds of
millions to impeach our president and
there was zero evidence but he's a
threat to democracy
what are you talking about
uh
you you guys don't remember the whole
perfect phone call thing where he was
withholding aid from ukraine which by
the way would have been pretty useful in
exchange for dirt on biden and he
ultimately was pressured into releasing
it i guess it's just a troll i don't
know
did putin threatened us with nukes
please explain vladimir putin announced
that as a response to the russian the
sanctions against russia
which he says are aggression
he is up upping
the nuclear force to a higher level of
readiness suggesting that he might use
nukes that's what putin did
we looked at the article at the top of
the stream i also have a video clip that
i published to youtube and it is utterly
insane utterly utterly insane
super chats are pouring in achievement
unlocked world war 3 2022 well let's
hope not
okay so we covered that
covered that
let me say a couple other thank yous
before we move on there's just such
great people supporting our stream today
on the last day of the month thanks to
mindy joy and cayenne pepper cayenne
pepper numbers 53 and 54.
incredible dumps of memberships are
coming in it's it's truly quite shocking
they call them dumps i want to say thank
you to dan
renery
jorge leon
martin robertson donna banks
jesus leon maybe brother signing up
yonatan renovichi
susan tucker
justin dussaj
rob manz thomas brown polly pelly
rodolfo inahosa
kevin hume
i can barely keep up with these anthony
pavick
devin boston bonnie canis
marissa woodburn john bowman
and sean henning thank you to all of you
putting us at 69.
um xe just gifted five also putting us
at 74. i'll open phone lines guys if we
get to a hundred yeah the big deal is
it's the last day of the month february
is often a tough month because it's a
shorter month it's wider but it is much
shorter only 28 days and so one day only
we have launched a probably against the
law coupon code
the code is no putin no february you've
got to spell it correctly and i can't
help you with that but the coupon code
is no putin no february and you can use
that code at
joinpackman.com and it's just shocking
what is going on i want to briefly check
in on what stephen kenneth
destiny
banette oh he's done
oh he has he was walking around
washington dc and i wanted to check out
what he was doing all right so that's
that let's see what hassan
destiny
[ __ ] the second is up to people have
been constantly telling me that hassan's
doing all sorts of things let's listen
classic uh putin [ __ ] where he's just
like saying whatever you know what i
mean
i've only watched hassan stream a few
times and i'm curious every a lot of
people contacting me and telling me
there's bad stuff happening unlikely to
survive this defeat meanwhile it's
unlikely that putin wins by the same
methods it's not that russian morale is
low it's rather that it depends on how
hard the war is most russian troops
would be enthusiastic or wouldn't mine
against a small foreign vacation with
fun and adventures fighting a hard long
war with the real possibility of death
is another matter
morale of russian troops is widely
overestimated according to my
sociological studies the main motivation
to enlist is usually to get an apartment
i don't know if this is true or not
but it makes sense i mean american
motivation is kind of like uh the the
american motivation being you know
college education free college
healthcare
and a little bit of fun and adventure
now
as a chance to get a housing of the
state now if you're dead you can't get
housing perhaps those already in ukraine
have little choice but the very fact
that the resistance continues wars
bloody and casualties are real would
hugely demotivate those back at home
expect no enthusiasm to go
there on the russian side
is he just reading tweets
start destroying infrastructure done
blockade city is done simply level
cities with bombers and artillery like
in chechnya or syria maybe
okay uh
putin's uh putin's attacks on
infrastructure uh are are severely
limited unless he means like
source trust unless he means like
infrastructure is literally like
military uh encampments and then and
then
misfires that end
up because he's saying he blockaded a
city and he started destroying
infrastructure he's saying done first
two would inflict humanitarian
catastrophe as he hopes to break the
will third one is problematic unlike
chechnya and syria where you could
easily justify open genocide with
fighting jihadis which is a fair play
in the war on terror he's not saying
that that's appropriate he's just saying
that message all right well i'm going to
be in la soon i'm going to go to
hassan's house and then we'll see what's
going on see uh
see what's up with that
so that's uh that's hassan's stream
um let me see so we did this already
and we did that
um okay
i have by the way if we want to look i
have like a sub list this is my private
list of sources that i have on twitch
just various video
twitter rather
um
let's see just some random things
freedom caucus won't say whether they
disavow nick fuentes that's that white
nationalist sure
i wanted to ask if the caucus is
committed to disavowing nick no we're
talking about what they're talking about
i said if you have questions for freedom
caucus members we'll take them after do
you have any questions of these fine
individuals that came to talk about
their lives being destroyed oof
a lot of strange stuff desantis says
putin is an authoritarian gas station
attendant
this is a guy who's basically an
authoritarian gas station attendant okay
with some legacy nuclear weapons from
the old soviet union they their whole
society is hollowed out except for that
energy and so if you want to hit him hit
him at the gas pump hit him hit him with
energy this is a
man desantis is really vile
pat robertson came out of retirement to
claim oh wow he is not looking good
that claim putin is being compelled by
god to invade ukraine in preparation for
a massive end times invasion of israel
oh my god i think you can say well
putin's out of his mind yes maybe so but
at the same time he's being compelled
where did his eyebrows go by god
he went into the ukraine but that wasn't
his goal his goal
was to move against israel ultimately
and god is getting ready to do something
amazing and that will be fulfilled and
what putin is doing by moving as he is
to set up ukraine as a
staging ground
for one of the armies and then across
his
is erdogan at turkey and and you've got
between them that little dardanelles
area and it's going to happen so i just
say
that is close i mean listen it's crazy
but it's better than most of the
analysis we saw at cpac that's for sure
i'll give him that
charlie kirk accuses ukraine of being
more interested in winning the
propaganda war than the kinetic war
people watching i'm sure have questions
such as the zelinski videos seem a
little too
rehearsed i'm not saying that zielinski
is not under threat how can you even
tell that unless you speak ukrainian
saying that zielinski is someone that
isn't likely going to be displaced by
the invading russians what i am saying
though is we know zielinski is an actor
we know that
zolensky was part of a hollywood
community in ukraine uh-oh
i think what he means is he's jewish i
had this
i had this tweet i put out i hope you
guys are following me on twitter by the
way it's a grand old time by the way
this picture of putin meeting with his
with his top these are his top advisors
his medium advisors have to be in a
different room when he meets with them
his top advisors just have to be 50 feet
away it's crazy
but anyway
what i tweeted yesterday was
um
[Music]
where was this
oh here it is when they criticize
zelensky for being a globalist puppet of
george soros they just mean he's jewish
right
and we also know that some of these
stories that a lot of people have been
publicizing such as the ukrainian border
patrol on snake island and many other
stories that we've heard such as the
ghost over kia kiev
are getting debunked
and
let's say
getting cross-examined in real time
ukraine is winning the propaganda war
that is for sure in fact it seems as if
ukraine is more worried about the
property it's just weird because like
objectively russia invaded ukraine
so what does he even really mean
you know like i mean they were invaded
it it sort of seems like he's saying it
only seems like they're the victims
because they're fighting the propaganda
war better or something it's very
strange
than they are actually about the kinetic
war well yeah i mean they're completely
overwhelmed
uh
if russia were to deploy its full
resources which it doesn't appear to
have done i mean what a weird take man
it's very very strange
um
yeah we're not even going to deal with
that that's just that's a no-go
we already looked at this clip we looked
at pat robertson a lot of people are
quoting these clips that's why they they
come up more than once
let me see if there's anything else that
i wanted to cover here
we looked at this clip already we looked
at this clip already
um oh wait a second
i guess this was a weird question
specifically does is the president will
he walk in
uh shake hands will he be wearing a mask
when he walks in well he will certainly
not be wearing a mask when he's speaking
i have not talked to him yet about
whether he's going to wear a mask when
he's walking down uh the aisle yeah so
by the way tomorrow night is the state
of venue of the union guys i really hope
you will all join me it's going to be
the first stream of march we're gonna
start an hour before biden starts now
for the love of god can someone confirm
that the speech is at nine because it
normally is
um joe biden's state of the union
schedule march 1 20 i just want someone
to confirm it's really at nine
nine pm beautiful so i will start at
eight pm eastern tomorrow and i do hope
that everybody joins me
i hope everybody joins me
uh all right so we looked at a few of
those things there
let me get over to
oh thanks to sterling lana and nasty
questions for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 76
the membership dumps continue to pour in
thanks to tracy steyer for signing up on
my website kathleen arnold is a new
member anthony phillips kilroy jenkins
jackie ott and angela hagen our new
members crystal heath vike
and brian de caney
stuart birch and c mao i guess that's
chairman mao
thank you for signing up putting us at
86. guys
we might actually do it if we get to 100
i'll open phone lines right now because
it's the last day of the month because
it's february we're saying bye bye to
february with the one day 75 off coupon
code no putin no february no putin no
february and that gives you access to
the bonus show oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad also thanks to izai for the twitch
subscription puts us at 87. guys we
might be able to do it we might be able
to do it let me get to some voicemails
the voicemail number is out of control
and another thing for michael knowles an
italian lady taught me how to yell and
talk [ __ ] trash
but guess what my brother taught me how
to fight and make an old lady [ __ ]
kiss the floor without a [ __ ] scratch
she dumb ass [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
whitney shot out of a cannon today
whitney completely shot out of a cannon
oh my god thanks to colors atk
if if today is the last day of
febrile screens
oh man this this is nuts
i'm gonna go get some pringle lips
a [ __ ] pig nose
and some extra fleshy stuff to put her
on my jaw and show you how [ __ ]
normal she looks
michael knowles
michael knows knowles is one of those
the wire the daily wire ben shapiro guys
and whitney is furious with him yes
that's propaganda we're seeing normal
people
should shut their [ __ ] nose you want
to hold a gun oh my god shot out of a
cannon eric from mass continuing to
deliver
disinformation
hey david it's over from mass can you
explain to me and you listen to us why
um the coven 19 contains a patented gene
uh sequence did he say coppa 19
considering i've called you before and
showed you the patentment number
actually guys know covet 19 is not a
patented bio weapon i'm sorry it's not a
patented bio weapon that's not true
thanks to waximus and sumi long
milo wild also gifting five subs guys
we're at 95.
this may genuinely happen we're at 95.
if we get to 100 the phone lines will be
blown wide open and you can use the
coupon code no putin no february just
today to sign up on my website
and number 100 i will give a free item
to from the online store let's end
february on on a high note
kim says david i just got notified i
leave for ukraine tomorrow as part of
foreign legion territorial defense of
ukraine wanted to say you're one of my
favorite news sources kim
be safe be safe be safe and check in if
you're able
uh wow
that's that's i would be scared
i would be scared
let me reiterate what i just said to
michael knowles again i want to make
sure he hears it loud and clear
if you guys are so [ __ ] normal
then get a gun and defend our country
people like me
are sick and tired of defending people
that call themselves normal
we're crazy
we're getting our babies taken away from
us
we don't look normal for you
right okay
by all means
let's have normalcy people defend our
country wow
well
i i don't know what michael knowles did
but he clearly did something to really
really set whitney off
so i wanted to speak to michael knowles
can you tell him that yes that is
propaganda normal people will get guns
they will go to war
i don't care what they look like and
that they have normal noses or whatever
if you want to take our guns
and say that normal people deserve guns
and the military
and the police and the army do not
then you [ __ ] pigs can go to
[ __ ] work wow
wow a major shot across the bow from
whitney i i don't really know what she's
talking about but it's it's a very very
high level of of activity
yes david pakman
what is happening in ukraine is the
national global tragedy
and unnecessary
what we are seeing is the eradication of
the people
and part of the cause is this troy
york's out of breath character this is a
new one without a doubt i put full cost
okay it's very very boring
you son of a [ __ ] you
why don't you [ __ ]
you
you know bite is just a [ __ ]
surrogate you son of a [ __ ] i don't
know why you won't just [ __ ] admit it
on your show
you know biden's [ __ ] he's just a
he's a surrogate for poop and i don't
know a surrogate for pooping that's
weird
why you
what does that mean is that a medical
issue
i don't know why you won't talk about it
on your show
i've never heard it
you know he's just a surrogate for putin
you david
you
you know he only
you know he only invaded ukraine because
of
biden being president
talk about it on your show stop ignoring
the subject
wow
people are really really struggling i
sort of have a regular gauge of the
mental health of the country based on
how many messages i get that are like
that
and i can tell you from the last five
days there is a lot of strife out there
folks there's a lot a lot of strife out
there just using using the calls i get
as an indicator very very difficult
stuff
very very difficult stuff i want to say
thank you to kyle edwards for signing up
on my website
thank you to debbie rosenblum
[Music]
and matt lilly thank you putting us at
one
hundred callers i'm sorry 100 members
let's take some calls okay
davidpakman.com discord also a huge
thank you
to jen here agent shadow gifted five on
twitch nikki's heels richie bird nation
and dm sasquatch putting us at 108 it's
a record-setting day flea girl is
dumping in a membership let's talk to
some people let me talk to some of you
we haven't done this for a while
uh oh let's see hold on
would i be interested in talking to
dylan burns about russia ukraine at some
point yeah i would do that
yeah let's do it
sometime soon that's cool i enjoyed my
last conversation with dylan burns that
sounds good guys if you want to talk to
me right now go on davidpakman.com
discord and get in the waiting lobby the
waiting lobby
okay
and then i will talk to some people this
is going to be a really great thing
we're going to close out february with
that
oh also thank you to the naughty reaper
for the twitch prime subscription really
appreciate everybody uh oh god and more
people signing up stephen roberts is a
new member using the code no putin no
february
eduardo delgado
signing up also that puts us at 112.
that coupon code expires at midnight
guys let's do it let's hear from some
people first guest today is emily emily
go
emily go
hey david sorry it took me a while down
mute um
uh i'm i'm just curious i have a hot
take here and and
and they're gone
i just i'm i'm not tolerating those
noises do not use push to talk turn
notifications off we just can't do it if
you fix it i'll consider going back to
you it's just too frustrating to the
audience it's blinging and blanging and
people just go absolutely crazy let's go
to shayna from california please shayna
rescue us
hi mr packman can you hear me yes i can
please call me david
hi david nice to meet you pleasure
um so uh i just signed up a couple of
minutes ago
you're an american hero i appreciate it
and i just want to say i like your show
you kind of situation that you shouldn't
panic you shouldn't scream about world
war three because panicking will make
things worse he's gonna start panic
buying and spraying rumors and there's
lots of chaos so don't panic stay calm
trust the president and he knows what
he's doing beautiful beautiful thank you
so much i appreciate the message of
peace and love and calm
okay i'll be here tomorrow for the state
of the union i'll be watching your
stream for that
beautiful where in california are you
shayna
sacramento okay i've never been there is
it nice i hear it's very hot
it's warmish yeah 70s
all right shayna thank you very much
what a day let's continue speaking to
different people roy from south jersey
you were next up
roy from south jersey
how are you i'm doing well
um you know i was just wondering because
um
i have a lot of family in the czech
republic and uh whatnot um
you know a lot of people there want to
go fight and a lot of people have uh
with the um
the foreign legion that ukraine has set
up right um do you think that that could
potentially cause you know relations
issues if they if russia sees a lot of
people going to join that
relations issues between between which
parties between the people the the
countries from which the people are
joining like czech republic poland even
the united states if some people decide
to go uh i don't know i mean russia's
got so many problems relationally with
with ulcerat i don't know that russia is
going to say oh the makeup of the people
coming or from these countries we're now
gonna start i mean russia is already not
getting along with most countries
because the world is mostly united
behind ukraine so no i don't think so i
don't think it's gonna be a big deal
okay and do you think that the uh the
crash of the roll and the freights and
all that will actually make a big impact
sorry do you you cut out do i think that
what will make an impact
with the uh the ruble collapsing uh the
interest rates being doubled in in one
day oh my god yeah i'm i'm reading that
it could take decades for russia to
recover from this economic calamity
perfect thank you okay all right there
it is uh roy seemingly liking that
liking that it could be decades uh
interesting reaction he seemed giddy
almost about it that was interesting um
okay i want to say thanks to jody
motionless as well as eldercroft for the
twitch prime subscriptions pushing us to
114.
also thank you to margaret banshee
for the
join pacman.com
membership you guys earned it we've
opened phone lines
let's go to adam from
mississippi adam go
hey david can you hear me i can
awesome thank you first of all a huge
fan i've been listening since like 2014
oh thank you and i signed up two years
ago uh and i'm loving the membership i
appreciate that uh
but i actually wanted to ask you first
um
do you think that
the situation in russia is going to
impact or in ukraine uh is going to
impact the american election like
personally on social media i've seen a
lot of comparisons between zielinski and
cruz
when he uh
when he when ted cruz decided to leave
uh texas
during the uh
finals you're saying unfavorable
comparisons to ted cruz ted cruz went to
cancun where zolensky said send me
bullets
correct yes uh but like i'm not sure if
and while i i agree with that comparison
i don't know if the people who are
hardline like ted cruz hardline right
wing supporters i don't know if they're
going to
be swayed by anything like that and same
with trump as you know uh trump said
right before
uh
putin decided to invade that
uh he that putin was very smart or
something like that yeah but again i
don't think that's going to sway a lot
of hard line right right wingers
hardline trumpets do you think that
might have any sort of impact no i tend
to agree with you i think the impact
will be minimal and republicans saw what
a disaster it was to be sort of
pro-putin in the first 72 hours of this
and they've already abandoned that now
they're sort of pretending to be
pro-ukraine so now i don't think it'll
hurt them much in the end
okay yeah thank you uh
that was it awesome thank you so much
thank you so much i appreciate the call
guys we have opened the phone lines
because we got to a hundred members on
the last day of february i want to say
thank you to jose hermosillo who just
signed up on my website and is new
member
116.
it is really a stunning stunning day
let's go net by the way just a reminder
anybody putting a parenthesis in discord
to get to the top of the list i will not
call on you that's a way to
not be in alphabetical order i don't go
top to bottom so you're just you're just
annoying me when you do the parentheses
and you won't get called on just as an
fyi let's go next to graham from indiana
graham go
graham from indiana please unmute you
are on the air
last chance for graham
from indiana
all right that's too bad
let's go how about jonathan from chicago
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
great so i just wanted to ask from your
perspective
of russian politics
i understand that it's not necessarily
good to waste the demise of any
individual but let's say
hypothetically
if putin were to be assassinated what
implications do you think that would
have within within russia you know i act
given the
given the russian public's opposition to
this invasion
i
you know me there are many times where
we say you know
you kill the number one
taliban guy
and the number two taliban guy becomes
the number one taliban guy everybody's
just as radicalized and nothing really
changes and i think that often that
assessment is correct in this particular
case
i believe that there is significant
opposition to putin even within the
ranks from people who are in line but
they don't really like it and they don't
feel that they can speak out they know
the russian people are against what
putin is doing and i think if putin were
to be assassinated
i think it would actually dramatically
change how russia would relate to the
rest of the world now
i don't think putin is going to be
assassinated i'm not advocating for a
state assassination of putin but i would
bet by my bottom dollar
that the idea of
you know what about an assassination has
100 percent been discussed by by some
western countries when
western leaders say give me all the
options
i am sure
someone has said and
if we were to think about an
assassination here's how we would look
at doing it i'm not saying it would
succeed but there is no way it hasn't
been discussed
and uh i don't think it's a good idea
politically i'm not advocating for it
i'm not calling for it but
an assassination of putin would have
different repercussions than like when
we assassinate the number one or two
taliban or isis leader for sure
thanks for answering my question man big
fan keep doing what you're doing all
right thank you very much appreciate the
call there's jonathan from chicago with
a very very specific and on point
question
thanks to gummy dave for the twitch
prime subscription your number 117
also thanks to riley benner for signing
up on my website with the coupon code
obama
today only you can use the coupon code
no putin no february all one word all
lowercase
to get an insanely discounted membership
and we are also taking calls
quite literally right now
let's go next to by the way i know i
don't have to say this with you guys
because you guys all have the right
phone etiquette
um if it takes you two minutes to get to
your question or a question hasn't been
asked in two minutes
i start to wonder whether any question
is coming so uh let's let's let's do
questions let's go to surya from new
jersey surya you're on the air
uh hey david i just had a question on if
you i'm not sure if you covered this on
yourself but this has to do with uh
the kind of
it's kind of been swept into the rug but
um the u.s bombing somalia and also the
uae and saudi arabia bombing yemen right
now at the same time as this invasion so
i was wondering what your thought your
thoughts were on that i'll be totally
honest i have not been following it i've
been so busy with the daily show and the
the ukrainian invasion uh i just
wouldn't i you know i don't i don't want
to blow smoke anywhere on you no matter
where i know no part of you in or out um
i just am not up to speed enough to
intelligently comment
okay that's fine thank you all right
there's surya from new jersey guys if i
don't know i'm not going to tell talk
about it you know i don't feel it
necessary to always have a take on
everything i just have not been
following it enough to say let's go to
matt from yorkshire
matt you were on the air
evening david how are you doing i'm
doing well what would it must it be like
whoa is it midnight there in yorkshire
uh 10 to 11 at night not far from
turning into bed i just uh figured have
a nosey stream and uh
quite interesting to see what's going on
in the world from from your perspective
i appreciate it thank you i appreciate
what you do um the
my question actually falls on from the
uh the fellow a couple calls ago were
you saying the uh
there's quite significant opposition
with the
people in russia to uh to putin's stance
and
and a lot of people seem to be against
him uh i'm curious what you think about
uh whether if we ever get to that
hellscape situation where if putin does
give the order to press the big red
button and launch nukes
is it in the realm of the possibility
that these top generals turn around and
go
no
i've i've thought about this right the
idea would be let's say putin says
launch the nukes
do
his top generals band together and just
say hell no
i think it's just mere speculation it's
it's meaningless speculation maybe i i
just don't think we have enough
intelligence to definitively say
what the mood is of those top generals
who would be in a position to say no
i i just have no idea it would be idle
speculation one way or the other yeah
yeah they made the the the only
real vision we've seen of any of them so
far have been of those uh those
announcements that he's posted up and i
mean facial
cues from them they look worried but
they look worried yeah and in some of
the pictures you know they're sitting 40
feet away from him at a table so it's
hard to even see their expressions
yeah
uh it's it's it's [ __ ] madness at this
point it's madness it's madness yeah
that's that's that's all i wanted to
come for um keep doing what you're doing
mate it's it's cracking work thank you
so much i appreciate it
have a good one all right you too
there is matt from yorkshire in the
united kingdom what a caller what a
caller
uh i want to say a huge thank you to
weldon perry
as well as christian foyer
who have just done the uh impossible and
they have gotten memberships on my
website and our new members 119
and 120
let's go next we're taking calls and it
is wild
let's go to ellie from seattle ellie you
are on the air
hey david can you hear me okay i can
hear you beautifully
thanks uh uh big fan thanks for taking
my call pleasure um
my question is you know with with
everything going on you know ukraine and
russia
[Applause]
and that everything you know locally
like florida and the don't say gay and
what's going on in texas with the trans
kids
all of this stuff how uh so i'm a mental
health therapist and i always wonder how
do people deal with like the information
overwhelm like the 24 hour news cycle
like how do you
how do you find a way to disconnect and
not let it like rule your life 24 7. so
basically a couple different things one
it's good to have a healthy under
understanding of like what's in your
circle of control
what's completely outside your circle of
control and where can you
like sort of have an impact but not
completely this is like very very basic
kind of like uh stoic type stuff and so
first of all it's like
when you if you want to be informed it's
important to to know when you're
consuming a new story is this something
i can even do anything about or not and
to kind of have a healthy understanding
of that number two it's really good to
have scheduled time away from this stuff
when i'm done with my friday show
unless we have like a specific weekend
event like this past weekend i had the
trump uh cpac speech on saturday but i
basically tune out of politics
completely and very often people will
ask me did you hear about this or that
and say no until i start preparing the
monday show i really have no idea so
it's good to
just take take time off as well from it
that those are the the two things i
would say everybody should do
awesome thank you
how's seattle by the way
uh rainey
yeah yeah yeah gotcha all right well
thank you ellie appreciate the call
thanks david all right ellie from
seattle
very very uh important
important question
why don't we try noah from california
next noah go
hey david uh i know you're a big coffee
guy i was wondering do you take your
coffee black
um i don't really drink drip coffee and
so black is a term that applies mostly
to drip coffee
i am really in the espresso universe so
it's not a relevant question to my
coffee
uh preferences i would say
oh wow very powerful well thank you
appreciate it that glad i was able to
clarify that
uh really the the pair issues of
paramount importance as you can imagine
today
um why don't we go to
uh
let's go to tony lasagna tony lasagna
you're on the air
oh hi david uh
been watching your show for a couple
years i honestly didn't think i get
called i was trying to change my
username oh all right well here we are
we find ourselves here together
we do um
so i want to make my question brief i
was having a discussion a couple days
ago with a friend about the
whole ukraine situation and
uh he was basically saying that the
the fact that basically uh you know
russia could attack with nuclear weapons
at any time is sort of something that
putin is holding over uh nato and the
other allies and i was saying that
he's like oh you know why couldn't you
just why couldn't nato attack and i was
saying well because then
putin would use nuclear weapons and he
was
and then he replied well basically
that's sort of an upper hand that putin
has how do you know that putin's gonna
attack with nuclear weapons and so i
guess i kind of thought about it um and
i understand like the the whole
uh
you know geopolitical thing of attacking
a
uh nuclear-powered nation but
um if you like what
what would be the the definitive reason
for why we wouldn't nato would not get
involved in sort of like a direct
conflict i think that with all these
things it it's it comes down to
it's a similar thing to when the initial
sanctions were announced and a lot of
people were saying well why aren't they
doing more sanctions here's a list of
more stuff that can be done
if you do everything right away even if
it would be the most effective way to
completely quash an invasion
you
take away
the possibility of doing things in the
future
and so
when there were the initial sanctions
after the invasion of the daniel x the
nietzsche and luhansk people were saying
well why not do more sanctions on
individuals
and then it was like well
it makes sense to wait to see if they go
to keefe then they went to keeve and
then they did more sanctions and it was
like well why aren't they doing swift
and then now they've done swift and so i
mean i think
obviously unless we're in the room we
don't know what the conversations are
but you want to make you want to keep
tools you don't want to use all your
tools right away you need to keep some
bullets for later so to speak to use an
analogy and i think that that's
generally
the principle that's at play here in
terms of why has not why has more not
already been done
okay that makes that actually makes
sense i haven't really thought about it
now unfortunately in so doing people do
die right like more people will die in
ukraine because of the use of that
principle
there's no way to deny that but it's a
commonly used principle when thinking
about responses
yeah
question oh by all means
okay um
so in that case
uh if
if we would you say that direct military
action
would
never be on the table or by us by us
troops or by nato forces by u.s troops
or by nato forces
uh nato forces okay no i think it is on
the table i i don't i mean i've not
heard anyone rule it out definitively
have you
uh no i haven't but
sort of but that would only be a direct
attack on a nato ally right not involved
with by
none probably
probably yeah okay
all right thank you so much david i'm
really glad to talk to you all right
thanks appreciate it there's tony
lasagna to everybody sending me direct
messages on discord
it's not going to get you on
just so you know there's there's a
process it's a very specific
and professional process to get on
um let's go next oh hold on i want to
thank a couple other people thanks to
relly475
for the twitch prime subscription
thanks to matthew gorgiska no gorjika
matthew gorjika who is new member 122.
today only for the next six hours we
have a 75
off coupon code on my website the code
is no putin
uh is that anderson cooper in the bottom
right what is that no putin no february
and uh it saves you 75 it's the last day
of the month it ends at midnight and we
are taking calls right now
let's go next to
uh oh let's go to bethany from oklahoma
bethany you're on the air
hi can you hear me i can bethenny we've
spoken before right
yes yeah this is maybe the third time or
something like that let me see what i
can remember i love doing this uh
bethany from oklahoma
you have multiple kids right
correct yes okay a three-year-old and a
seven-year-old i don't remember anything
else other than that but it's great to
have you back we talked about bagels one
time that's right oh i asked you if we
could get good bagels in oklahoma and
you said not really right
well i mean not
not probably what you're used to okay
this is a place called old school bagel
cafe it's it's right old school bagel
cafe yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
you know the big thing now i don't want
to get off track but
i'm sure you're familiar with an
everything bagel right
oh the everything bagel yes i'm familiar
with it the new thing that i'm loving is
an everywhere bagel which is an
everything bagel but they put the things
on all sides of it so the bot because
the bottom of the bagel often has no
seeds and and other elements flavor
elements yeah the everywhere is an
everything bagel with the stuff all
around it it's fantastic
i have not heard of that it's pretty
good when i go there um i like to get
the i think it's called the
it's like called the french toast bagel
or something like that it's very sweet
and cinnamony and i get my breakfast
bagels with it bethany i am so against
that but i don't want to let it ruin
this call so let's move on to something
else
okay so um
i guess my main uh question was
well i have a friend and he actually
worked for a little while in you said
it's like the
united states
um
oh assistance usa id
yes that's it yeah yep and um and he
worked there for a few years
working with humanitarian aid for russia
and so i got his opinion on everything
that's going on and
he essentially
kind of said that he doesn't think we
should
have ever even promised
that that we would he he doesn't think
we should have let nato um
ukraine join nato at all because we
can't
keep our promise and so
the thought experiment that he gave me
was he said uh you know if
like what would what would america do
if russia got
like had gotten canada or had gotten
mexico to join the uh warsaw pact
and he so he was like that's he was kind
of provoking like that's the thought
experiment he's like would we not
do anything in response to that
and and so i
i felt like and i what i said back to
him is
well if they had done that
years and years later and it was still
around maybe a different story but do
you think there's any merit to
you know we just
shouldn't have had it on the table at
all for ukraine
to join nato because of the
our inability to really like want to go
and defend it ourselves no no i don't i
don't that doesn't sound like a very
good argument i mean listen you cr if
you believe that ukraine is a sovereign
country that can make its own decisions
ukraine has every
right to and just so we bethany we're on
the same page that ukraine isn't part of
nato i don't i don't want to just assume
that you know that but you know but i'm
guessing you do you do okay yeah yeah
yeah um if ukraine wants to join nato
and ukraine could decide whether to join
nato if nato wanted to have ukraine join
nato
why would nato preemptively say ukraine
can never join i mean it's just not
there's no reason for that now we can
accept that if you are russia you can
reasonably perceive an expansion of nato
as something that's encroaching on you i
don't deny that at all like okay that's
fine it doesn't give you the right to go
and invade ukraine
see that's i mean that's essentially
where i fell i
what what he said i kind of felt like it
it seemed like that's um walking on
eggshells
around a dictator to just go out of our
way to not want to do the littlest thing
to provoke him i mean that's kind of how
i felt about it but
i mean it was an interesting you know
thinking if
russia had done that with one of our
close allies we're not allies but
bordering neighbors um
but but i'm on the same page as you i
i don't think we should have said no you
can't join either um yeah and i know a
lot of people will say
hey all you americans supporting ukraine
if russia suddenly put a base right over
the u.s mexico border
you would consider it aggression and
it's like yes yes that's true
uh but that wouldn't just happen and the
circumstances are totally different and
the backstory would be completely it's
just not it's not really analogous
exactly and that's what i said to him is
i said if russia did that if they you
know
did a parallel type thing it would
probably be
if it's a parallel type situation it
would be in response
to us probably being aggressive first
because i mean russia is the aggressor
in this and that's why ukraine
is you know seeking obviously more
security um
so i i just want to get your thought on
that but yeah no it sounds like you and
i are more or less on the same page on
that
yeah yeah i agree with you um i have a
couple random questions too that i've
just been meaning to ask and i always
forget
um
when do you take calls like throughout
the week because on your you know daily
shows every friday right
it seems like you're taking new calls
and i just like every once in a while i
randomly hop in during that time but is
there like a scheduled time we
pre-record those we pre-record those
wednesday wednesday at 12 15 eastern
wednesday 12 15 eastern yeah
gotcha i was wondering when you
pre-recorded those wednesdays 12 15
eastern
um and then one last question
um i am i've joined i'm a member now so
i have been for a while thank you um
and i've realized because i came across
one of your videos on facebook the other
day and so i was just you know watching
like a short segment on there
and then i realized you know you started
to go into one of your promos and i miss
the cool things that you promote and
that you give discounts
you're missing the ads bethany i don't
think we've ever had a phone call like
this you missed the ads
is there a place on your website where
you put like these promo codes and stuff
so i'm
like not because you you suggest cool
stuff usually and you know more so than
most people we do have a sponsors page
under about on the website and we try to
keep it updated we try to keep it
updated okay
gotcha good to know i i'll have to check
that out because i was like i don't
really want to
go watch the just generic ones just for
that reason you know i i do like
watching the member remember exclusive
channels of course of course
awesome well thank you so much for
taking my call bethany it's been a
pleasure bethany from oklahoma french
toast bagels
that's a real question mark but
otherwise a beautiful beautiful phone
call
um let's see who else we can talk to by
the way thanks to bobo fetra as well as
micro kimmy birchlore rangers gifted
five subs via twitch that's a total of
seven putting us at 129 and then the
things happening on the website nobody's
ever seen before michael casolino just
signed up
ophir almag just signed up seems like a
turkish name omar nunez just signed up
three new members putting us at
132. oh and also anthony martinez
putting us at 1 33 what a day folks the
phone lines are explosive
let's speak next to
oh i don't know
what looks interesting where is a place
we've not spoken to anyone from maybe
ever
maybe ever
hmm
oh hold on here's a caller from india
the country we've had callers from
bangladesh but i don't think from india
caller from india i can't see your name
because it's too it's just off the
screen what was your name
hi david this is stranger from bengal in
india srin joy is that the right
pronunciation
that is correct wow welcome thank you
now are you from the are you from one of
the regions that is predominantly
vegetarian i'm not familiar
no no no no okay
it would be fine if you were you acted
almost like no god no no i'm just
curious
no no we eat everything you eat
everything okay good all right please
proceed
so if i may i have one recommendation
and one question please
um since you're watching a clip from we
on news where the ukrainian mp is
carrying a gun in his car yes i want to
turn your attention to a video from ndtv
where another mp pulls out his
kalashnikov to counter a reporter from
sputnik tv in a debate
is that new
yeah it's a few hours ago oh wow okay
i'm going to look that up but just
because it sounds edgy so i'm not going
to do it on the stream because i don't
want to get i don't have a problem
anywhere yeah
yeah yeah it is a news channel in india
beautiful
and
the my question is that um have you seen
the racism that is occurring at the
border of ukraine poland ukraine hungary
and all those stuff okay african and
indian students
so listen
i have i i don't know what the truth is
yet about that because
i've heard the allegations
and i've heard denials
and i i just don't know to what degree
that's true if it's happening it's
absolutely condemnable but i it's been
denied
and yeah i i just don't know
yeah yeah so so what happened it started
from the polish officers okay so um so
first they were prioritizing the
ukrainian citizens to cross over and
stopping africans and indians okay
basically indian students who have gone
there for medical
stuff
also africans
then what happened after that is since
india abstained from the vote against
russia yeah the ukrainian police also
started uh being against the indians
okay yeah i
i the allegations are very i just want
to be careful because there's so many
different claims being made about that
yeah so
you might want to check that out i will
i will absolutely uh okay i i appreciate
the call very much i believe you're the
first caller we've had from india at
least recently
oh my pleasure thank you so much all
right there is srinjoy from india thank
you so much guys that's such a perfect
call
that i think on that note we're gonna
rap uh it's just i don't know that we
could really do any better than that
um i appreciate everybody who joined me
it's been an incredible final day of
february
tomorrow
eight east five west
in the night time obviously
state of the union
state of the union we will be here
and
guys i don't know what else to say it's
just been an incredible stream
and i'll be back with you tomorrow thank
you